how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in Donald there are three kinds of
lies said Disraeli in a phrase that was
popularized by Mark Twain lies damned
lies and statistics
I suppose that's inclusive enough to
cover the variety and number of
falsehoods that surround us these days
though there are times when I wonder
after all we now live in a universe of
fake news think of breaks it think but
because I mean don't think of Trump on
the day that I began writing this talk
the Washington Post calculated that the
president president and you get as you
gather I live in America had told more
than 4,000 whoppers during the first 20
months of his 10 years it's actually now
about 5,000 think but really I don't
need to go on you all know what I mean
what role can poets play as we BA belong
on this current and what do poets mean
when they talk about the truth of poetry
that's what I want to talk about and I'm
going to organize my thoughts around a
handful of phrases that the poets have
come up with over the centuries all of
which contain the word truth or true and
I hope by the end that I've clarified
what I think is the paradox that governs
the whole notion this in essence is the
paradox that I mean politicians
philosophers and anyone whose main
purpose is to demonstrate a process of
logical thought teachers for instance
like myself generally aim to spell an
exact proposition a version of events
that we their audience may or may not
agree with poets on the other hand
deploy imagery that is not dictated by
the need to make a case and use diction
that is determined as much or more by
sound as it is by semantics even such a
poet as Dryden who insisted that the
words comprising a poem are the image
and ornament of the thought it contains
and added that the primary purpose of a
poem was to convey the apprehension of
that thought even Dryden understood
as a guards at any of these pages will
confirm so these are the tendencies we
see when we are being asked to consider
whether my mistress eyes might or might
not be like the Sun Sun would be nicely
and it also explains why so many poets
and even a few critics echo Archibald
MacLeish his famous dictum that the poem
should not mean but be John Keats for
instance we hate poetry that has a
powerful design on us a husband poetry
is not the thing said but a way of
saying it TS Eliot a poet has not a
personality to express but a particular
medium which is only a medium and not a
personality Wallace Stevens some people
always know exactly what they think I'm
afraid that I am NOT one of those people
I a Richards it is never what a poem
says that matters but what it is William
Carlos Williams only the imagination is
real all these remarks seem to describe
a clear distinction between what is
poetry and what is not yet if we think
again about the phrase a poem should not
mean but be we realized that it makes
and does not make sense and just about
equal parts how can a poem not mean
words do mean things and all lines of
poetry including many of the greatest
inevitably and unavoidably have a
propositional purpose that business
about my mistress eyes for one this is
no country for old men books are a load
of crap the examples are numberless and
the point they demonstrate is very well
summarized along with much else by
beautiful sentence in the preface to the
lyrical ballads poetry is the breadth
and finer spirit of all knowledge
carrying sensation into the midst of all
objects of science itself here was worth
creates a balance that helps us
understand the relationship between
meaning and being he registers his
engagement with things as they are
science itself but at the same time
suggests we might and most completely
understand them by some means other than
or in addition to strictly rational
comprehension by sensation indeed but
proves the truth of poetry is not to be
found in direct state
or judgments was existed in one place in
one alone but in the difficulties and
idiosyncrasies of individual words and
syntax and in the imaginative
enlargements of metaphor Octavio Paz has
something good to say about this what
characterizes a poem he tells us is it's
necessary dependence on words as much as
it struggled to transcend them well I'll
come back to these notions in the moment
but now I need to give you some
background and to show how they've
evolved over time and I want to begin by
painting the backdrop which of course
means that I need to talk about Plato a
bit how in the Republic rejects the idea
that poets and truth tellers of any kind
I'll remind you book 10 of the Republic
opens with the assertion that poets Mame
the thought of those who hear them
because according to the Platonic scheme
of things they are doomed to be
imitators that's to say original and
ideal forms are created by a god
craftsmen make early representations of
these things and poets when they write
about them merely create an image in the
world of becoming poets in other words
exist at a third remove from what they
represent in their lines or as Plato
himself says they are thrice removed
from the king and from the truth this
remove it nests in which an idea of
imitation among idea of deception or
actual lying are conflated is the fatal
weakness in poets from which all other
defects grow Plato tells us because
poets don't know the original truth
about anything they really have no idea
what they're talking about and because
they don't know what they're talking
about
they have no means of putting what they
claim - any kind of test this is what
makes them so dangerous for him they
have a disastrously partial view of the
world that are continually trying to
seduce their audience into a state of
mental laxness in which passions of
various kinds had the upper hand and
reason is overthrown maybe in a society
considers as a mass of individuals this
wouldn't be the end of the world but in
the ideal community conceived by Plato
there is no clear separation between
public and private worlds therefore by
posing a risk individuals poets also
threaten the entire state that's why
they have to go into exile and once
they've been expelled what are their
chances of returning
pleasure does allow the possibility by
two means he suggests that poetry might
make a defense of itself in lyrical or
some other meter and he realized that
those who are lovers of poetry might
show not only that she is pleasant but
also useful to the state and to human
life for if it can be so proved we shall
surely be the gainers I mean if there be
a use in poetry as well as a delight use
and delight they presented here as sort
of opposites and yet when we cast our
mind over the whole body of the Republic
we realized that Plato has not been true
to his own word although in no sense a
poem the essays in the Republic use
rhetorical and other strategies that
commonly appear in poems it aims to make
its case to be philosophically useful at
the same time as it seeks to hold our
attention to be delightful in other
words for all its certainty about the
dangers posed by poets and their lying
it can't avoid suggesting that some
intermingling of truth and invention of
squaring up to reality and allowing for
elaboration presenting cold facts and
ytterbium with warm language might not
just be unavoidable but actually
desirable jump forward 1,800 years to
1850 and listen to so Philip Sidney in
the defense of poetry his treatise was
produced produced in the response to an
I forgotten book called the school of
abuse by a Puritan writer called Stephen
Gosselin who before dismissing purchase
of the a waste of time
accused it in a platonic fashion of
being the mother of lies and the nurse
of abuse those phrases are Sydney's
actually by this stage so many Greek and
Roman poets displayed the spy plato's
sincere a defended poetry is a divine
power bestowed by the gods themselves
the Sidney fields no need to turn first
to the idea of truthfulness instead he
focuses on the idea that poetry derives
from a natural world but only to improve
on it nature never set forth the urge in
so Richard tapestry as diverse poets
have done he says her world is brazen
the poet's only deliver a golden only
once this premise has been established
as Sydney turned to the charges leveled
against posed by Plato letting him off
several hooks by arguing that the
Republic only ever meant prose stamping
out the abuse of poetry rather than
poets
selves then Sydney dismisses the
accusation opposed of fakers by seeing
the success and value of their work
doesn't depend on her accurately renders
reality but rather on how well it
interprets its subject in other words he
proposes that poets can't be called
Liars since it's never their intention
to tell a realistic truths in the first
place they don't share the ambition of
historians and astronomers as he says to
gain a knowledge of life that sets them
on a level with God their intention
instead is to communicate feeling and to
discover its recurring patterns and
because these patterns are universal he
is able to consider the poet of all
writers under the Sun the least liar
this line of argument is pretty much in
line with the ideas I sketched at the
beginning of the talk not least because
it licenses the idea of Persia as a form
of play a formal elaboration or
decoration of the facts and it's this
aspect of the defense Sidney's defense
that Shakespeare develops in a famous
passage of the dialogue between
touchstone the fool at Duke seniors
court and Audrey the goatherd in act 3
scene 4 you've as you like it touchstone
says truly I would the gods that may be
poetical to Audrey who means your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in aaaggghhh